taliban forces say they've taken
complete control of the last afghan
province resisting their rule
battles had been raging for days in the
mountainous province of pansher which is
north of kabul
the taliban spokesman zabihullah
said they had been seeking a peaceful
resolution but faced continued defiance
the national resistance front has denied
that the area has been captured and says
it is still fighting
when our delegations went there they
received negative answers and they
couldn't resolve matters through
negotiations and dialogue so the islamic
emirate decided to send military forces
to get rid of this violent nest of
terrorism we want a peaceful country and
if anybody causes problems or causes
insecurity anywhere in afghanistan the
islamic emirate of afghanistan will make
a decision and not allow anyone to
congregate and act against our
government let's go to speak to our
correspondent charles stratford who's
live in kabul uh charles
so do we believe this to be a true
statement uh and if so how significant
is this victory over panshir
well certainly this is the first time
that we've heard an official statement
from the official taliban spokesperson
we've had numerous claims made by
commanders
and taliban sources over recent days
so yes we are taking this seriously
there was some fairly comprehensive
details given in that press conference
by um by the by the press spokesperson
we've heard absolutely nothing since
then from the
leadership of the nrf it was last night
that a statement was put onto facebook
by ahmad masood the leader of the nrf
saying that he was wanting to negotiate
with the taliban
an indication of just how much pressure
those anti-taliban forces were under um
you know this is hugely significant if
indeed it is the case there have been
reports unconfirmed reports of of minor
clashes ongoing but as as we know the
taliban have never had full control of
this area the soviets during the 1980s
never had full control either so if the
taliban have indeed achieved this then
it is a huge historical significance but
of course there are big fears about the
civilian population of that area around
150 to 200 000 people
um the taliban spokesperson was
saying that there had been according to
him no civilian casualties he said that
uh panshiris as he calls them should be
treated with as much respect the same
amount of respect as uh people from
anywhere in afghanistan bear in mind
that pancheeris are mainly ethnic tajik
and the ethnic tajik community
population of this country represents
about a quarter
of the population so um obviously the
taliban trying to reach out it seems to
to to
in a call of unity after what we
understand has been days of heavy
fighting
um he said that there'd been food
shortages also inside the valley um and
he said that food would be supplied
to the area to people in the valley he
said that
electricity and communication would
probably be turned back on as well
it was
very much it wasn't a victory speech
although there was some fairly heated
language used in it as well that
possibly the international community and
afghans indeed will be looking at and
trying to interpret when he said that
this was the last in his words nest of
terrorism
that uh had been dealt with in the
country whilst at the same time sort of
building on this ideas that we've heard
consistently and was mentioned again in
the press conference of the taliban
wants to
form a
inclusive government a government that
brings in all the voices ethnic
minorities religious minorities of this
country which of course is so vital if
it is going to get legitimacy here in
afghanistan and the wider world
many thanks for that charles stratford
their first live in kabul